so it goes back to you got to mourn the
gap there right it's not what it once
was and that's okay everybody grew up
everybody had kids nobody moved that's
awesome
but now you got to own what it is and
what it is is you don't have any friends
i had to call people to my house in
nashville and say i'm new here will you
will you be my friend it's one of the
most awkward conversations of my life
right
and i've been to ob gyn meetings with
like like appointments with my wife that
was awkward this is level up like hey
will you be my friend
and one guy laughed and was like dude
you just made this super weird and i've
known him for a while so it's cool and
then i think i've told you guys the
other like another dude just got like
cried
like man no one's ever asked me that so
um you've got to be intentional about
saying
i pick you i'm going to invest in you
right and i got to decide that and after
six months
if it's not a good investment
it's a sunk cost me walk away from it
right learn from it and walk away from